good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in the middle of the
night last month bagram air base which
was about 30 miles north of kabul
plunged into darkness nothing like that
had ever happened before bagram is more
than an air base it's an enormous piece
of property it's the size of a small
town they had a hospital shops gyms two
runways rows of hangars and barracks
as of last month bagram also had a
prison it held thousands of foreign
fighters including men from isis and the
taliban
and then all of a sudden for the first
time in 20 years the lights went out at
bagram locals understood immediately
what was going on without warning or
even a courtesy notification the us
military just left split in the middle
of the night and turned off the power as
they did
ultimately the base's new afghan
commander fled too and so within minutes
looters descended they found thousands
of vehicles at bagram hundreds of them
armored as well as a huge cache of
weapons and ammunition
now the pentagon didn't seem concerned
mark mille the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff had explained already
that quote
bagram is not necessary tactically for
what we're going to do in afghanistan
end quote
that turns out to be a massive
miscalculation that's now clear the
decision to abandon bagram airfield was
in fact idiotic and it led directly to
the killing of 13 american servicemen
yesterday with bagram abandoned the
evacuation of afghanistan is being
staged from a commercial airport in the
capital and given its location kabul's
airport is almost impossible to defend
yet despite the fact it can't really be
defended it remains the only way for
american citizens to get out of the
country
as bill rajio the editor of the long war
journal put it abandoning bagram air
base quote is the perfect example the
generals just saluting and saying yes
sir and can do
and not standing up and saying this is
madness and i can execute this because
i'm putting the lives of americans at
risk and you need to find someone else
to do it
tragically no one in authority was brave
enough to say that instead at every turn
they made unwise decisions that seemed
designed to make the country they serve
weaker to humiliate the united states
what's interesting is that these very
same people are now overseeing what may
be the largest airlift in generations an
airlift of thousands of afghan citizens
into the west and into our country so
how is that airlift going you're hearing
a lot about it but very few details who
example for example are all these
afghans
many of whom are on their way here
the truth is despite what they are
telling you we have no real idea who
they are we just don't know
we just learned for example that at
least a hundred of the refugees the
american military has flown out of kabul
people we've been told repeatedly are
heroes by definition are in fact on
terror watch lists one man we evacuated
apparently works directly for isis
today an afghan interpreter told fox
news that this sort of thing is
happening all the time
people are getting on planes in kabul
without any proof of identification
whatsoever it's like voting in
california listen
i know people that they're at the same
situation that i am right now they have
voted for the united states they have
provided supply for the united states
but guess what
over there are people that are getting
inside the airport that they have never
worked
they knew somebody with a green card
they know somebody with a passport
that's how they got to inside i know
people that they are inside
but they never work
so that's not an analyst on msnbc that's
someone at the kabul airport and if you
listen carefully you hear a lot of
stories just like that one
one pilot with united airlines someone
who's flying people out of kabul as part
of the civilian reserve airlift fleet
just told fox news he was simply told to
evacuate people from afghanistan no
details beyond that the pilot said he
was never given a passenger manifest and
when his airplane arrived at dulles
airport outside washington the state
department refused to share any
passenger information with customs and
border patrol they just whisked right on
through
that means as always unnamed foreign
nationals got far better treatment than
you would get if you landed at dulles
airport
surprised
but again there's a lot of this
another commercial airline employee a
flight attendant just told this show
that her flight crew was told they'd be
ferrying american civilians who would
escape from kabul and she was happy to
do that but when they arrived in qatar
in the gulf they learned that in fact
they'd be carrying no american citizens
at all none
instead they'd have to transport afghan
nationals many of whom became unruly on
the flight and by the way since these
weren't american citizens they didn't
have to wear masks rules like that are
only for you and the rest of us who are
paying for it they don't apply
to people without passports from
afghanistan
now that may shock you but trust us it's
normal in washington the democratic
party is actively demanding it of course
they view every refugee as a potential
new voter you remember that sandy cortez
was very worried about all those
unvetted trump voters wandering through
what they thought was their capital on
january 6th sandy cortez thought she
might be raped despite the fact she
wasn't even there at the time
but strangely cortez so sensitive about
her own safety is not in the least
concerned about sending huge and still
unknown numbers of refugees into your
neighborhood
she has seen we have all seen what
afghan migration has done to europe over
the past six years and apparently she
approves of it she wants more in order
to to carry out and in order to make
good on the role that we have played in
this violence we have a responsibility
to make a home for the people whose
lives have been upended by intervention
interventionist u.s foreign policy and
so as a result i'm i'm proud to have
co-led a letter with representative
barbara lee to ask thee and urge the
biden administration to
as they set their their refugee quotas
to make it no less than 200 000
so the macro question is why does silly
children like that have any power
whatsoever in this country why should
some girl from bu who knows nothing has
never done anything in her whole life be
in charge of the way your country looks
going forward for the next hundred years
who knows that's democracy as we
practice it but listen carefully what
she's saying
no fewer than 200 000 refugees why
because we're evil and we deserve it
wait a second
we shouldn't spend 20 years in
afghanistan but why did we go there in
the first place well because al qaeda
was using it as a base from which to
blow up the world trade centers and
attack the pentagon there was a reason
we went there in the first place even if
the occupation thanks to people like
alexandria ocasio-cortez turned out to
be a total disaster
so we don't owe the country anything
they were the staging ground for 9
11. she was a child at the time doesn't
remember that but her view now has
bipartisan support in the city of
washington it's not just democrats we're
sad to report here's republican adam
kinzinger for example a man who not only
weeps for nancy pelosi's super fans on
the capitol hill police department but
also for foreign nationals on the no-fly
list
they're painting
afghan refugees as invaders you know
there are undertones even of
racism here what you see is in the media
eco chamber this fear-mongering right
this they're coming to your neighborhood
these hordes of people that haven't been
vetted i mean that is not american
refugees to this country have always
been the ones that are extremely
entrepreneurial i mean we all know that
they come here they work hard they fight
hard
to for success
and so if anybody wants to go out and
fear monger and continue that darkness
in your heart and speak in it so you can
win an election a you're either evil at
your heart yourself or b you're a
charlatan who's only interested in
winning re-election you truly can't say
you care about the healthy american
people
okay wait a second son we can debate how
many afghan refugees we admit but making
this a matter of racism pashtuns are
whiter than you are they have beards but
there's nothing racist about having
concerns about afghans or anybody else
moving here it has nothing to do with
race so knock it off
but listen to what he's saying
foreigners are more impressive than you
are they're more entrepreneurial you
learn that at a coke seminar and if you
don't agree with that said adam
kinzinger if you thought the point of
america was to serve the people who live
here the americans you are and we're
quoting
evil
that's his position you're evil
so now you know why adam kinser isn't
bothered at all by what the bible
administration is doing now with the
southern border which is opening it
he's not bothered because he agrees with
the result fewer native born whiners
those people can go die of obesity and
fentanyl ods more grateful foreigners to
whom
who feel indebted to us people we can
claim to have rescued
so adam kinzinger is obviously a
transparently pathetic and odious person
and we don't mean to beat up on him he
literally cries when he thinks about
what a good person he is so we don't
want to single him out the point is that
his attitudes
less childishly expressed are very
common in washington and the numbers
prove it since july the united states
has evacuated more than a hundred
thousand people from afghanistan all
heroes all americans no as of tonight
just about 5 000 of that total are
american citizens that's five percent
so you're thinking the others 95 must be
heroes right all translators 95
000 translators that's what cnn is
telling you
but no
just today the state department admitted
it has no idea how many of these people
have what we're calling special
immigrant visas that would indicate they
actually worked with the us military and
might be heroes maybe even translators
so no they're not all heroes we don't
know who they are
in the context of this massive in many
ways unprecedented evacuation effort our
first goal is to has been to bring as
many people to safety as quickly as
possible so in many cases
we are going to be in a better position
to provide you fidelity on numbers uh in
the coming days and the coming weeks as
this process has been ongoing uh our
goal has been to put as many people on
as many planes
as we can
so to restate they're not all heroes
we can't say that because we don't know
who they are
the head of u.s northern command general
glenn van hurk just admitted this he
told our jennifer griffin that more than
half of the afghan refugees coming into
the united states do not have special
immigrant visas so they didn't work for
the us military they're not heroes
they're not translators so why do we
have a moral obligation to let them live
here and give them free health care
we have no proof that they're loyal we
don't even know if they're
entrepreneurial
as adam kinser might say so why are we
taking him into the country one military
won't say
instead the pentagon is just doing it
and then building housing for them
today the department of defense can
announce
that it is authorized marine corps base
quantico virginia
fort pickett virginia and holloman air
force base new mexico to provide
additional support to the u.s mission to
evacuate afghan special immigrant visa
applicants their families and other
at-risk individuals
these installations join fort lee fort
mccoy
fort bliss and joint base maguire dixon
providing this support
the defense department will continue to
support the state department in
providing temporary housing sustainment
and support inside the united states
for a capacity of up to 50 000 afghan
special immigrant visa applicants their
families and other at-risk individuals
man they always take tragedy and they
run with it
to change this country outside
the bounds of democracy they don't ask
anyone to vote on it they don't ask your
permission
they just take your sadness and
bewilderment and they leverage it to
change everything they did that with
george floyd's death they did it with
covid which they helped create through
gain of function research and they're
doing it now
in the wake of the tragedy in
afghanistan that they cost
so we just learned that 50 000 sv
applicants plus their families and
here's the key phrase and other at-risk
individuals
so what you ask is an at-risk individual
we have no idea but it's a term our
military is using a lot
today the head of u.s central command
again used that term at-risk afghans
right now it seems like anyone in
afghanistan is at risk
and that seems to be the body
administration's assumption as well cbs
news is reporting that some of these
at-risk individuals are now being housed
in u.s government shelters meanwhile
soldiers at fort bliss are building new
temporary housing as part of what
they're calling operation allies refuge
now allies refuge that sounds like
something all of us can get behind
offering refuge to our allies
then you realize who these allies might
be the pentagon now considers the
taliban an ally we're giving the taliban
lists of americans who are still in
afghanistan as well as other classified
intelligence we're also giving them
fleet free plane rides to our country
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else